hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from round five of the
2019 Greinke chess classic it's Vincent
camera versus Gehrig Meier I'm sorry I
wasn't able to cover it yesterday I was
catching the premiere of The Avengers
end game and I'm not gonna spoil
anything for you I'm just gonna say the
bar has been set pretty high for all the
movies of a similar genre to follow and
I I must say it was quite an end game
one of the best I've seen so far and
getting back to this game are really an
interesting one and it features one move
that is so so awesome that you're gonna
remember this game by by this move so
without further ado well we do have some
footage but maybe maybe save that until
the end game so let's check it out when
Vincent has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 so far Vincent zero points
in the tournament Gehrig Meier one point
II 6 we have c4 Knight to f6 winsome
pose for Knight to f3 and of course the
Queen's Gambit the client is on the
board Knight to c3 D captures on c4 and
now II four and b5 one of the rare lines
of the Queen's can be declined where it
is okay to defended the c4 pawn we have
E 5 and then out comes Knight to d5 by
Meier also an interesting line is before
but it if you know correctly play the
white two will always end up a pawn up
after pawn captures pawn captures here
pawn captures here now you have to play
something with the Queen B five but now
just Queen to a4 check who will pick up
the pawn there should be seven now F
captors and g7 first threatening to win
the rook and bring another Queen into
the game captures Emma Lyndon Queen
captures on c4 well where black would
have several options to choose from but
in the end he will always be down upon
so after a 5 we have Knight to d5 by Mar
and Knight captures on b5
nice to b6 and Bishop to e2 preparing
the kastle-meyer simply continues
developing pieces we have Knight the c6
castles by Vincent and Bishop to e7 and
here Queen to d2 you might think why
Queen to d2 why not Bishop to e3
developing the bishop well the idea is
okay for the moment
Queen d2 blocks the development of the
bishop but you want to go Queen to f4 to
g3 and its Queen d2 is actually an
attacking move and here in this position
it it was played to two months ago in
the RR fold open in February between
Andre penguin Park amok Sulu mock Zulu
won the game with the black pieces he
castles here but here we have Bishop the
b7 by Meier postponing castling for the
moment and Vincent continues in this
fashion Queen to f4 for the moment the
knife and Queen are guarding the the d4
pawn so you need to get rook to d1 and
before going Queen g3 Queen to d7 still
deciding on whether to Castle King said
or Queen said but chances are it will be
a queenside castle Knight back to c3 and
h6 preparing g5 black is announcing that
he's not interested in castling kingside
we have looked at e1 now the rookie at
the pawn on d4 his defender twice Queen
g3 will be played g5 Queen to g3 and now
comes queenside castle so the black king
is very safe here so we'll see what
happens
Bishop to e3 and now comes Knight the B
for a nice square for the knight tonight
to c2 will be a possibility in the
future maybe even Knight 2 D 3 depending
on what white plays first we have night
2 D 2 now creating a double attack
against the c4 pawn and h5 Meyer decides
there's no way to defend this we'll just
continue with our attack on the King
side Knight captures on c4 and now comes
g4 an interesting line arises after h4
for for example Knight captures here
with check a captures and now Queen to
h3 and now rugby to GA preparing to
further push the pawn but the problem
for black is that white doesn't really
have anything to worry about white can
just start pushing on the Queen side and
after g4 it's not a problem I can just
capture Bishop captures here and now
even though you have this rook on g8
Bishop on b7 there's no way to take
advantage of this even if you position
the Queen on d5 let's say 9505
captures captures and Queen B 5 even
with the Bishop Queen and rook eyeing
that g2 pawn you still have no way of
breaking through this
Bishop on g4 is just an excellent piece
and even though with the Queen being
passive on h3 it's just working out for
white so but but it's an amazing line
white just continues a captures
repositions the rooks and should have a
winning game so Meyer decides to go g4
we have Knight captures on b6 first a
capture Sun b6 and now Bishop to b5 a
very nice move as the Queen doesn't
really have anywhere to go
you have to block if you block with c6
then your Bishop no longer has this
beautiful diagonal so butter up to c6 is
played and now Bishop captures we have
Queen captures on c6 and now Queen to a
for getting the Queen out of the line of
these pawns and also preparing to
capture on f7 Meier defends it we have
rook beat f8 and now a very nice
temporary pawn sacrifice by Vincent you
want to break through in the center
Vincent goes for d5 so of course you do
have to capture Knight captures
displayed Knight captures and now he
captures on d5 and of course the queen
is now guarding the d5 pawn so there's
no problem but rook a to c1 kicking the
Queen out of the way we have Queen to b7
and now comes Queen to f5 check clearing
the d7 square for the White Queen for
the White Queen and now you you have a
couple of problems here if you go into
the center then a very dangerous idea is
Bishop captures on b6 this is what
Vincent had in mind where you don't
really have all that many things if you
capture with the Queen then you no
longer guard the d5 pawn a mating attack
is about to happen and if of course you
capture with the C pawn then again you
get rook captures with Czech Queen
captures and rook to c8 checkmate this
was a Vincent's idea and Meier has to
react accordingly so after Queen to f7
you have to go back and allow Queen to
infiltrate with Queen to d7
now the bishop is under attack the pawn
is under attack twice and c5 is played
now the Queen is guarding the bishop
here but it's not a problem for Vincent
and now the black king is quite loose
you could go for something like Queen b5
and hope for something let's say but
before six maybe we could go for a nice
rook lift
but Vincent keeps it simple instead of
Queen b5 keeping Queens on the board he
just grabs his temporarily sacrificed
pawn and says I'm up for a nice endgame
where I'm a pawn you know are you game
Garrick and Garrick decides that he is
game we have Queen captures rook
captures on d5 and now comes to rook to
d8 offering a trade of rooks rook to d1
by Vincent and now you can see that the
position is well both both players two
rooks both players the dark square
bishop and the Vincent still up a pawn
so what what will happen before we check
it out let's check out some nice footage
I've cleared my Ram cache so it should
be everything should be in order here we
have a nice some nice footage of Vincent
I think it's about from this position so
that's why I saved it for this moment
just giving you know it's not a stare
maybe a few glances towards Meier and
also we have some nice footage of
Vincent here making a move just you know
moving that rope it's a few moves after
this position we have on the board but
still and you can see that he has some
nice fizzy water to to be used as a
refreshment King to c7 now black of
course wants to get his King into the
game as you should when playing an
endgame King to f1 Vincent does the same
king c6 improving the position of the
king king he - and now rook hd8 and now
f4 and now you could play for characters
captures and then f4 White will still be
able to protect his central pawn but
Margot's for f6 pawn captures Bishop
captures now attacking the b2 pawn and
here just rope capture son d8 route
capture son d8 + b3 getting his pawns on
the Queen side to light squares so the
bishop will not be able to attack them
and the now comes rook to e8 and here
King to d3
if Vincent starts improving the position
of his skin but Mar doesn't allow it
rook b8 check and now if you just go
forward just rook e8 check you're gonna
have to keep an eye on your bishop so
you will not be able to keep improving
the position of your king
that's why vinson goes back with King to
c2 but now a market takes this
opportunity to increase the activity of
his own king first rook to e8 attacks
Bishop rook to e1 now preparing to the
trade rooks but now King D five Myer
finds a very nice way to activate his
King we have a four and the now comes
rook to e4 and here Vincent forces
afraid of rooks will rush up to d2 rook
captures any one Bishop captures any one
and King to e4 so although Vincent is up
a pawn you can see that Mars king is
already occupying the e4 square and dead
in that in itself is compensation for
the pawn and here is the move that I
enjoy most in this game what do you play
here with white the problem is if you
play something like g3 to cement your
pawn structure here then you allow the
skin to further infiltrate your king
site each is gonna gobble up the pawns
and not something you want to do he's
gonna go Bishop to d4 and it's just just
a very nice position for black but
another thing that I thought would
happen is Bishop to f2 with some ideas
that you can you know push here grab
this one or you can you know if the
position gets complicated you can maybe
capture here and start pushing this guy
depending on what what black does with
the dark square bishop it is unlikely
but most likely something like King
captures here what happened you would
gain the d3 square for your King you
would keep on playing this game even
though you would have to give up some
material but here what happened in the
game is just beautiful here Vincent
played f5 and it's a it's a very
interesting move of course if King
captures then Vincent gets the d3 square
for his King but here a Meier actually
doesn't capture here amar decides to
improve the position before capturing on
f5 and he plays h4 and why not you know
the f5 point is not going anywhere it's
on a light square I'm just going to be
able to capture it next move but here he
actually blunders the game here Vincent
has a a winning move and well it's it's
hard to imagine but you know he
definitely should have captured it
immediately but feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
move for Vincent I'll give you a couple
of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
in-game player and for those who've just
wanna enjoy the show Busch of the c3 and
now the problem is you cannot not trade
the bishop's if you just move the bishop
back f6 is coming after bishop moves
even f7 is coming and now after the King
starts moving towards the f7 pawn you
just play b4 and now after pawn captures
Bishop dd4 here you're gonna eliminate
this point and there will be no stopping
the apon King e6 you can capture here
King captures and now after a 5 you
cannot prevent the pawn from reaching a7
as the light square Bishop covers all
the important squares so the game is
winning for white so Meier decided to
capture here with King captures and now
King captures on f5 and now you have
this position where the material is
completely equal but Vincent is first to
clear the way for his past a pawn king
to c4 we have King to f4 King to b5 King
to e3 and now King captures on b6 King
to f2 and now a five instant already
starts pushing his passed pawn king
captures an G to A six now King captures
on h2 and now a7
we have g3 Meier now starts pushing his
passport as well and now aah Queen
we have g2 and now we have this very
nice sequence of moves where Meyer had
our Vincent has to go left and right
with his Queen to reach the black King
King is three Queen the ch-check King h2
Queen c7 checking h3 Queen d7 check King
H - quinta d6 check King H 326 check
King H 225 check King h3 and now Queen T
1 guarding the queening square we have
c4 by black and here you can see that
Meier is still very much into the game
it's just a beautiful move where if
Vincent accepts the pawn pawn captures
then you get pawn to g1 a promoted or
queen with check and now of course you
have to capture and now it still mated
the black king has nowhere to go he has
no pawn moves it's a you know it's
stalemate so Vincent of course doesn't
grab the pawn we have b4 now comes c3
King to c6 it means the now
makes room for his own passport see -
and now Queen to see one blocking the
pond and waiting for the black king to
make a move we have King - H - and only
now Queen captures on C - where where
the Queen out pins the G - pawn king
back to h3 Queen d3 check King - H - and
now comes Queen to e2 again pinning the
pawn king h3 Queen III check King CH 2
and now Queen to f2 again pinning the
pawn we have h3 and the now comes b5
again Winston starts pushing the passed
pawn king - h1 and now Queen to g3
saying yeah sure you can you're free to
promote this pawn to a queen but if you
do that I'm just gonna capture here
deliver check if you block I'll capture
capture and then b6 is winning as there
is of course no stopping the pawn so
after Queen g3 we have h2 by Myer and
now comes Queen to f3 again pinning the
pawn king to g1 and now Queen - III
check and here we have the point of this
line that Vincent chose you have to know
this by heart otherwise you're not gonna
be able to win games like minson the
problem is if you go king - h1 here it's
a force mating - but of course you all
know this checkmate as we've already
shown it on this channel plenty of times
I just queen to e4 black has no moves
black has to go King to g1 it is the
only move and then you deliver 20 e 1
this will be checkmate so and you should
remember this if this is the position in
your opponent plays king each one just
Queenie for pin the pawn for the King
here not there here and then deliver
checkmate
so amar had to go King to f1 and now
Vincent has the Queen to f4 check just
hoping to win this pawn Meier blocks and
now comes B 6 and finally Mar gets a
queen into the game but it will not do
him all that much good with upon 2 h 1
queen b7 notice that the White Queen
prevents any checks from the black Queen
we have Queen to h7 and now just be it
with another Queen so now Vince it has
two queens which is of course almost
always better than one Queen King - h1
hoping to get another Queen into the
game but now just Queen to f3 again
painting the pawn
quinta see to check we have King to d5
Queen to d2 check King to e4
now comes Queen to see to check King the
e5 and after Queen to c5 check we have
King to f6 we have Queen to d4 check and
here Vinson just played King to g6 and
it was in this position unmoved 81 that
Jeremiah resigned the game and the
Vincent scored his first point in this
super tournament quite an amazing win
against such a strong Grandmaster like
Derek Meyer there are no more checks so
there are no more tricks there's nothing
you can try this Queen controls
whoa this Queen controls the d6 square
so you cannot deliver check there this
screen controls d3 so no checks there
and all the other squares are covered so
here you could try any move but then
it's just a force checkmate in whatever
way why to choose this be one checking
h2 now queen h5 checking g3 Queen e1
check you can go King before and then
Queen f5 will of course be checkmate
so after King g6 my resigned the game
and a wonderful victory for younger
vincent climber so first wind comes in
round 5 which is not all that bad
considering who he faced he faced Carson
Khurana on an I ditch and in the Gehrig
Mayer now so one out of five you know is
is a dream basically yeah as usual if
you know are interested there are around
for impressions in the description below
sorry round five impressions in the
description below and also a very nice
interview with Vincent Kaymer after his
victory against Gary Mayer if you are
missing some laughter in your life to
check it out after seeing Vincent laughs
you will also enjoy a good laugh
yourself I would like to thank mark
groans oh man Arunachal some mark fan
out heads and David Patterson David
Peterson and Glen fine for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and I have to say
after watching the end game yesterday
and then getting home and seeing this
same game I was very impressed you know
the two such good end games in one day
is really you know a day improver yeah
yeah I think you all I will see you soon
have an excellent rest of your day